yeah i don't like to end it lebron
james's review of squid game is now
getting a review of its own from the
creator of the show
[Music]
during a post-game press conference
earlier this month the nba star revealed
to teammate anthony davis his thoughts
about the series's final scene obviously
we're entering spoiler alert territory
here yep i didn't finish
different shots
[Music]
interview with the guardian the squid
games creator responded to lebron's
comments and threw a little jab back the
nba baller's way asking the outlet have
you seen space jam 2 what in the matrix
hell
let's rewind squid game became the
internet's obsession when netflix
released it last month the korean series
gained celeb fans including carrie
washington billy eilish and jimmy fallon
the cast also popped up on the tonight
show hey sue when did you realize uh the
show became so big
right now
but with all the love comes some hate
which brings us back to lebron's
reaction to this final moment
foreign
[Music]
yeah i don't like to end it though
so i know i know they started off for
the season two were like
see the dog
what are you doing but now it's all love
between lebron and squid games creator
who went on to tell the guardian quote
lebron james is cool and can say what he
wants i respect that i'm very thankful
he watched the whole series and for what
it's worth and maybe most importantly
the creator says he's very happy with
the show's ending smile
[Music]
you